we want to talk to you about structure
and archetypes and even a crossover of
Mythology versus some of the romantic
comedy themes why do people set out to
write romantic comedies why do you feel
that it's there's a lot of people in
Hollywood pitching these scripts I think
the reason that a Chandra comes into a
trend or a fad is often the success of a
film or a TV show in that particularly
genre example being zombie stories I
mean for years when we go to the great
American pitchfest
and you look at what people are looking
for it was zombie this zombie that
vampire horror thriller give me some
more zombies for the last couple of
years no one's asking for zombies okay
so Jean recycle in and out of popularity
but I think romantic comedies tend to be
consistent because the people who write
them have had some kind of an experience
that they want to share with the world
or maybe okay so I have this theory and
I think facts will prove me out winners
right history losers write about love
because the losers aren't doing anything
they lost in love so they're the ones
who are right about love and idealize it
and how they think it should be so I
think a lot of the people who write
romantic comedies are those who are
trying to create a reality that they
could inhabit yeah and then sometimes
it's because well gee that's what the
market is looking for because some
writers do write towards the market
although we're always told you'll get a
much better story if you write it from
here or from here rather than oh yeah
it's going to be popular it's going to
make a billion dollars love is at the
center of so many people's lives whether
it's they've got plenty or they don't
and so a romantic comedy can be a way of
dealing with that for yourself I think
and also sometimes either warning or
encouraging other people about falling
in love
so that and this is no pun intended but
always a bridesmaid never a bride kind
of a feeling and so they feel like they
have to somehow fulfill that on paper
and through a film I think so and the
the film 27 dresses is a very good
example of that someone who is always a
bridesmaid was always helping other
people but she never had her own love
and so through the course of that story
it's about how she comes to realize that
you know she does deserve love and she's
been helping all these other people
maybe it's time to look after herself so
again who writes romantic comedies
I had one writer friend who was a very
good writer and he wrote a romantic
comedy was starting it when he was
dating this girl and he was really in
love and then they broke up and oh my
goodness that script changed and it
turned into a horror film I said now you
you are aware of what's going on here
aren't you so how one feels about love
at the moment is certainly going to
dictate the kind of story that you write
and I think we would all be well served
by having more stories that do put forth
as the romantic comedies in the book do
joy dignity passion and integrity when
relating to love
you